a ver a ver en el vídeo pasado que me
quedo larguísimo pero pues yo ni modo no
estábamos hablando acerca del basketball
y decíamos que yo tenía un porcentaje de
anotación de tiros libres de 80 por
ciento aunque entonces más o menos en
los últimos mil tiros anoté como 800 y
entonces suponemos que si me coloco en
la línea de tiro libre más o menos hay
una probabilidad de punto 8 de que anoté
ese tiro libre y por aquí calculamos
cuál era la probabilidad de que anotara
yo tres veces seguidas y encontramos que
era puntos 512 pero bueno vamos a seguir
con esto de los tiros libres pero
necesitamos un poco de espacio entonces
voy a borrar esto
pero bueno continuando con esto del
basketball supongamos que estoy jugando
con un equipo y que además mi equipo va
perdiendo por un punto
entiendo
y punto además queda un solo segundo un
solo segundo del partido y estoy yo
justo en la línea de tiro libre ok
entonces si tiro y anotó voy a ganar
tres puntos para mi equipo y vamos a
ganar porque además queda un solo
segundo y no puede pasar nada más sin
embargo llega alguien más del otro
equipo y me hace un faul horrible y ya
no puedo tirar pero por suerte ahí
estaba el réferi y entonces me da tres
tiros libres tres tiros libres y cada
uno de esos tres tiros libres cuenta un
punto
entonces la pregunta que nos queremos
hacer ahorita es cuál es la probabilidad
de que empatemos y cuál es la
probabilidad de que haya un
para ti bueno aunque sabes que más bien
vamos a sacar cuál es la probabilidad de
que nuestro equipo empate
ya no habrá para que empate tengo que
meter exactamente un tiro libre y fallar
los otros dos ok pero nosotros queremos
que el equipo empate o gane para ganar
necesito meter dos o tres de los tiros
libres entonces la probabilidad de que
nuestro equipo empate o gane es igual a
la probabilidad de meter por lo menos un
tiro libre cierto
x
tiro libre
ahora que tan complicado crees que sea
calcular esta probabilidad bueno pues
resulta que no es nada complicado de
hecho vimos un ejemplo del truco que
tenemos que usar en el vídeo pasado esta
probabilidad es exactamente igual a 1
menos la probabilidad de
haber dime cuál probabilidad tenemos que
poner por aquí pues lo opuesto de meter
por lo menos un tiro libre es no meter
ningún tiro libre de scioto entonces por
aquí tenemos que calcular la
probabilidad de no
meter
ninguno
tiro libre a la canasta al parecer
necesitamos todavía más espacio
y aquí aunque lo haya borrado es muy
importante recordar que más o menos
anotó el 80 por ciento de los tiros
libres que tiro ok o equivalentemente
fallo más o menos el 20% de los tiros
libres que tiro o sea que también
podríamos decir que hay una probabilidad
de punto 8 de que anote el próximo tiro
libre que yo tiré pero bueno entonces
tenemos que calcular esta probabilidad a
ver cuál es la probabilidad
mete
ninguno ni 1
de los tres tiros libres y cuál es esta
probabilidad pues aquí estamos viendo
que la probabilidad de si meter cada uno
de esos tiros libres es punto 8 y
entonces 1 - p qué es la probabilidad de
no meter un tiro libre es igual a punto
2 y se supone que cada tiro libre que yo
tiro es independiente de lo que haya
sucedido anteriormente aunque bueno
quién sabe si eso sea cierto de verdad
porque seguro hay basquetbolistas que si
fallan un tiro es más probable que falla
en el siguiente tiro pero bueno vamos a
continuar pensando que los tiros libres
son independientes de todo lo que haya
pasado antes y entonces la probabilidad
de no meter ninguno de los tres tiros
libres es igual a la probabilidad de no
meter el primero punto 2
por la probabilidad de no meter el
segundo
punto 2 por la probabilidad de no meter
el tercero que es punto 2 entonces esto
es igual el punto 2 por punto 2 es igual
a punto 0 4 y tenemos que multiplicar
por punto 2 y esto es igual a haber
punto 0 4 por punto 2 2 por 4 es 8 y
tenemos
123 lugares a la derecha de los puntos
decimales entonces tenemos
123 lugares a la derecha del punto
decimal y listo entonces la probabilidad
de que mi equipo empate o gane es igual
a 1 - puntos 0 08 o sea tiene una
probabilidad de
punto 99 2 o sea que es casi seguro que
empatemos o ganemos si quieres también
lo podemos ver con porcentajes tal vez
eso te parece más claro esto lo que dice
es que
a ver recorremos el punto dos lugares a
la derecha y nos queda punto 8 por
ciento de probabilidad de que no metamos
ninguno de los tres tiros libres es muy
bajo para ser porcentaje cierto y como
tenemos punto 8% de no meter ninguno de
los tres tiros libres o sea tenemos
punto 8 por ciento de probabilidad de
perder entonces tenemos
99 puntos 2 por ciento de probabilidad
de ganar o empatar ok este y éste nos
dicen exactamente lo mismo aunque y
entonces básicamente ya ganamos o
empatamos el partido aunque porque esta
probabilidad es súper alta y ahora nos
podemos empezar a preguntar un montón de
cosas por ejemplo qué pasa si en lugar
de darnos tres tiros libres ahora nos
dan dos tiros libres pues igual tenemos
que calcular la probabilidad de meter
por lo menos un tiro libre pero ahora en
lugar de tener tres tiros libres tenemos
dos tiros libres entonces tenemos que
calcular un menos la probabilidad de no
meter ninguno de los dos tiros libres
entonces aquí sólo tenemos que
multiplicar la probabilidad de fallar
dos tiros libres que es punto 04 así es
que hay una probabilidad de 4 % de
fallar
ya dos tiros libres y por lo tanto si el
réferi nos da únicamente dos tiros
libres tenemos una probabilidad del 96
por ciento de empatar o ganar de empatar
empatar o
y ganar y bueno si el réferi te da
únicamente un tiro libre pues ya sabes
exactamente cuál es la probabilidad de
que empates el partido no o sea si
tienes un solo tiro libre para empezar
tu equipo ya no puede ganar aunque solo
puede empatar porque tu equipo va
perdiendo por un punto y además sabes
que para empatar tienes que meter ese
tiro libre pero también sabes que metes
ese tiro libre con probabilidad punto 8
entonces ya está tienes un 80 por ciento
de probabilidad de hacer que tu equipo
empate bueno espero que te acuerdes de
este vídeo cada que veas un partido de
básquetbol igual y esto de las
probabilidades te pone un poco en
perspectiva como para saber qué tan
probable es que gane un equipo o el otro
en fin algo que no se nos debe de pasar
por alto es que estamos haciendo esta
suposición de que el segundo tiro no
depende en lo más mínimo del primer tiro
o sea aquí estamos suponiendo que si el
jugador acaba de meter un balón o justo
acaba de fallar no afecta en lo más
mínimo a la probabilidad de que meta el
siguiente
me parece que es un muy buen proyecto
tratar de averiguar qué tanto es cierta
esta hipótesis o qué tanto el segundo
tiro depende del resultado de la
anterior que podrías ponerte tú y un
amigo a practicar los tiros libres y
tratar de ver qué tanto se relacionan
ese sería un muy buen proyecto de
ciencia pero bueno vamos a ver con otros
ejemplos
ahora vamos a hablar acerca de los dados
porque hay muchísimos ejemplos de
probabilidad que usan dados entonces
supongamos que estamos jugando con dos
dados de seis caras cada uno y pues
siempre es interesante preguntarnos cuál
es por ejemplo la probabilidad de que
nos salga un 7 bueno para encontrar esta
probabilidad voy a hacer una cuadrícula
por acá ponemos la por acá
y ahora quiero dividir esto más o menos
y luego cada una de estas partes la
quiero dividir entre 3
y para que hice la cuadrícula pues para
calcular las probabilidades de todas las
combinaciones que nos pueden salir con
los dos dados
ok de este lado vamos a poner todos los
resultados que nos pueden salir en el
lado 1 nos puede salir 1 2 3
456 esas son todas las caras del dado 1
y de este lado vamos a poner lo que nos
puede salir en el dado 2
1 2
56 en realidad no importa mucho si no
sabemos distinguir entre el dado 1 y el
dado 2 pero bueno para que no quede
demasiado largo este vídeo vamos a dejar
esto para el próximo vídeo